aquí tengo este vehículo que recorre 150
kilómetros en tres horas lo que quiero
que veamos es encontrar una forma
razonable para describir la rapidez de
este vehículo durante este tiempo los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y piensen
en ello
una vez que encontremos la rapidez
veremos qué formas de expresar la
razonables y no tan razonables primero
recordemos que es la rapidez tenemos que
la distancia es igual a la rapidez por
el tiempo si dividimos ambos lados de
esta igualdad entre el tiempo nos va a
quedar distancia entre tiempo esto entre
tiempo estos se van nos queda que la
distancia entre el tiempo es igual a la
rapidez nos dan la distancia nos dan el
tiempo para sólo nos queda hacer la
operación dividir la distancia entre el
tiempo aquí quiero conservar las
unidades ya que es muy importante
reconocer que las unidades hasta cierto
punto se pueden manipular de manera
algebraica recordemos que no son
variables pero siguen las mismas reglas
de una variable por ejemplo la rapidez
es igual a la distancia de la distancia
nos dicen que son 150 kilómetros entre
el tiempo el tiempo son tres horas
diremos la parte numérica 150 entre 3
badass 50 la rapidez va a ser igual a 50
ahora veamos las unidades que unidades
tengo tengo kilómetros entre horas
kilómetros por hora esta es una forma
razonable de expresar la rapidez a esto
es a lo que me refería cuando mencioné
que podemos realizar la operación
numérica y también dejar las unidades de
esta manera como estaban antes
mantenerlas de manera algebraica en un
momento verán que podemos manipularlas
aún más usando lo que se conoce como
análisis dimensional esta es una manera
razonable de expresar la rapidez puedo
imaginar que en una hora este auto
recorre 50 kilómetros pensemos en otras
maneras que podemos representar esto
ahora haremos un análisis dimensional
que damos que son 50 kilómetros
por ahora digamos que ahora quiero
expresar lo en kilómetros por segundo
cómo podemos hacer esto reflexionemos en
lo siguiente si yo recorro esto en una
hora cuando podré recorrer en un segundo
más o menos los segundos son un periodo
de tiempo mucho más corto hay 3600
segundos en una hora así que recordemos
1 entre 3600 partes de esta distancia
pero veamos cómo se comporta viendo las
unidades queremos deshacernos de estas
horas que se encuentran en el
denominador de manera que tendré que
multiplicar esto por algo que tenga
horas en el numerador y adonde quiero
llegar hasta tener kilómetros por
segundo necesito tener segundos aquí
abajo a cuántos segundos es igual una
hora si yo tengo aquí una hora tendré
3600 segundos en esa hora a esto es a lo
que me refería con que al hacer el
análisis dimensional como lo estamos
haciendo podemos manipular las unidades
como variables algebraicas
en este caso tengo horas en el numerador
horas en este denominador y me va a
quedar que esto es igual a 50 por 1
entre 3.650 por 1 entre 3.600 esta es la
parte numérica
ahora que nos quedan las unidades pues
sólo tenemos kilómetros y segundos
kilómetros
por segundo y esto no es tan intuitivo
aquí iríamos uno entre 3600 veces en un
segundo lo que serían 50 en una hora y
esto no es tan intuitivo vamos a hacer
la operación simplificamos esto lo voy a
escribir aquí arriba 50 por 150 entre
3600 puedo quitar estos ceros me queda 5
entre 360 esto no lo puedo simplificar
tan directo pero sí puedo multiplicar el
numerador y el denominador por 2
esto me quedaría 5 por 2 10 360 por 2
serían 720 y aquí puedo quitar este 0 y
este de acá me queda 1 entre 72 así que
esto es igual a un 72 a vos de
kilómetros por segundo esto está
bastante difícil de visualizar puedo
afirmar que estos no son unas unidades
razonables para este ejemplo en
particular un 72 sabe de kilómetros por
segundo pues no nos ayuda mucho a
imaginar la rapidez
este vehículo hagamos la operación
sacamos la calculadora y escribimos 1
entre 72 nos da 0.03 se redondeamos a 9
esto es igual a 0.01 39 de kilómetros
por segundo
está bastante extraña esta unidad
realmente no me puedo imaginar esto yo
digo que este 50 kilómetros por hora es
una forma muy buena de representar la
rapidez porque me permite imaginar
recorrer 50 kilómetros en una hora pero
qué pasaría si busco dejar esto en
términos de una unidad más grande como
por ejemplo metros por segundo quedamos
entonces que es 0.01 39 kilómetros por
segundo ahora lo quiero dejar en metros
por segundo
sabemos que un kilómetro es igual a
milímetros si pensamos en esto en
términos de metros por segundo tendremos
aquí un número
grande más grande de hecho por un factor
de 1000 y trataremos de convertir estos
kilómetros a metros como lo puedo hacer
si tenemos kilómetros en el numerador
deberemos tener kilómetros en el
denominador de lo que multipliquemos un
kilómetro y aquí arriba quiero tener
metros cuántos metros hay en un
kilómetro pues hay 1000 metros
metros pues tratando de estas unidades
como variables algebraicas puedo
cancelar estos kilómetros de acá con
estos de acá y quedarme con estas
unidades de metro por segundo y tengo
que hacer esta operación médica de esto
multiplicarlo por esto esto es igual al
punto cero 139 por 1000 vamos a mover el
punto décima de tres lugares a la
derecha nos va a quedar 13.9 metros por
segundo esto lo puedo imaginar sin
problema sé cuántos son 13.9 metros y
que éstos se recorren en un segundo ésta
también es una manera razonable de
expresar la rapidez puede imaginar este
vehículo recorriendo 50 kilómetros en
una hora o casi 14 metros en un segundo
pero
172 ago de kilómetros por segundo
no es razonable en lo absoluto de hecho
si quisiera imaginar metros por hora
tampoco sería fácil de visualizar vamos
a hacerlo
tomemos nuestros 50 kilómetros por hora
y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por 1.000
metros
en un kilómetro estos kilómetros se van
multiplicó sin cuenta por mil y me
quedan cincuenta mil metros por hora y
este es un número muy grande y esta
descripción de la rapidez no parece muy
útil ya que no me permite imaginar o
visualizar esta rapidez al igual que
tenerlo en kilómetros por segundo